so when you're working with David on the
script right do you guys just play
rock-paper-scissors over who's gonna
direct the thing like how I workout no
at the time we started writing I hadn't
directed a movie at that point we
started writing or planning it out in
2012 and the idea of me directing it was
just like that's never gonna happen
right I went to where actually this all
started when I asked her I pitched the
thing and and got told yeah you go away
and write it i sat on Bondi Beach with
David yeah because I've worked with him
on Animal Kingdom and I was like how do
you feel about making a version of some
kind of version of Henry the fifth and I
thought he would be like I don't know
but he leant into it yeah and I was like
good he can direct thing we'll write it
together but I ain't directing it is it
a love of like the era or a love of
Shakespeare it's a love of the plays and
I had performed you know it's
interesting kind of cycle because when I
was 25 I made how yeah in Henry for one
or two on stage in Sydney and actually
around Australia and then we did henry v
the following year yeah so I played that
character and I just had such a kind of
love of that whole story the father-son
dynamic that Bo father in Falstaff yeah
young King kind of coming into politics
thinking he could do things better and
then been corrupted by his the system
that he thought he could change all that
stuff you know this is such a visceral
telling of the story like the the
visuals are so acute and sometimes like
it's dirty it's bloody when you're in
the middle of that field and that scene
the big battle scene no spoilers yeah
hey how many people are out there isn't
really just a big mess out there
it's a massive mess I mean to put it in
perspective we have you know obviously
we augment crowd so we have like I think
we had like 300 extras 70 stunt cars
bunch of extras all in armored horses in
full armor 70 of them and and we were
constantly crowding this foot deep pool
of mud you know particularly in the
later stages of the battle and there was
one day I think on the dailies you could
see me trying to get up and you could
hear on the track
I can't like terrified voice like I
can't get out of things I thought I was
gonna like just get stuck in the mud and
drown but you hear you mean it I'm here
but it was fun as well yeah because you
know you don't get to be like you don't
get to live out your ten year old
fantasy of being like on a horse with a
sword too often yeah got all the girl
you know and I did
Timothy brings the drip on the red
carpet and brings the was he breathing
trip his outfits outfits oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah does that do you feel pressure
that I feel like I'm anointed look you
know I think if I brought that kind of
drape I'd just look like an old guy and
in a young trip you know anime I looked
Timothy's amazing there's this whole new
world and it's sort of you know it's a
very fitting thing for him to be playing
this character it's like yeah you know
in his own life is experiencing a kind
of sitting on a new sort of throne and
feeling it out and handling it very well
and having to navigate the economy in a
circle of Hollywood and and and the
movie business and you know but yet on
the red carpet the drip drip never hurts
really I'm gonna use up yeah you can you
brought your drip today thank you
appreciate that sir